hey welcome back to another edition of
The Gadget Lab podcast I'm Mike Isaac
I'm Christina Bonnington this week
phones we have more phones we have
Nokia's new sort of flagship us
smartphone and it's it's running windows
right and it's running Windows Microsoft
Windows Phone 7 this is well 7.5
actually yeah so this is basically
Nokia's major shift or play into being
an actual relevant smartphone in the
United States because right because they
mostly ship like dumb phones feature
phones so the Nokia that we're all used
to in the states at least is the fat
clunkers of yesteryear right the big
fatties that were sorry the obese phones
that were in in our pockets in high
school or things like that you know so
that's a lot of what they ship around
the world outside the United States but
obviously we're only concerned with the
United States and so we need our
smartphones here and they are doing this
new push so nokia is partnering with
microsoft to really get behind the
Windows Phone platform which as of yet
is still way behind Android and iOS
obviously do you think that's going to
help push Windows Phone into more
consumers hands yeah maybe I mean it's
it's an uphill battle for both companies
obviously I mean they have something
like two percent market share right now
platform share which is really rough
considering the other to the other
positions of the other manufacturers but
at the same time Android started off
small iOS started off small you know you
never know what could happen people
might like the funky color this is
actually the n9 this is what I showed
you last week but it's not the real
phone so is it this is not the real
phone but it looks exactly like this
only right and runs a windows phone so
so anyway that is coming out in the US I
believe in 2012 no exact date yet they
just kind of teased us with the new
phones and it's in Europe right now but
we don't know what carriers we don't
know when it's coming out just next year
so we'll see we'll see if it works in
other news in other
is these steve jobs biography any
mountain on monday of course it didn't
oh the much-anticipated biography of
Steve Jobs definitely so what do you
think you have you cracked it I have
cracked it what do you think I've
cracked it I think it's a good
entertaining read um fat to it is fat
yeah I mean tons of stuff was leaked
online beforehand you know we were
seeing all sorts of juicy tidbits and
stuff and so it kind of felt for a
little while like you know do you really
need to buy it why am I reading this
book if I've read everything online
already yeah right but it's it's
definitely an interesting read it
doesn't sugarcoat Steve Jobs yeah i mean
the the the funny thing is i mean we all
knew that Steve was like a hard la I'm
about a third of the way through the
book right now we all knew he was sort
of an intense guy right here's a
perfectionist but he's kind of a big
in this book and and that's and
that's part of the point though it's
like part of what made him so good as a
product guy was the fact that he just
didn't take less than perfection for an
answer right and he didn't want to read
the book before hand he had input on the
cover but not on what was inside the
book and his wife also didn't want to
see the book before hand so it's not
like it hasn't been like approved by
student jobs anyway yeah sure you're all
reading it or whatever right now we'll
see how it turns out you know don't tell
me how it ends anyway there's some other
iOS news this week or would it so one of
the tell me about one of the
introductions that Apple made with iOS 5
I believe right so new instruction on
the home screen with iOS 5 is something
called newsstand and it's a folder where
you can collect your app subscriptions
so like the wiretap New York Times all
these digital era nations yeah right um
and it's it's basically it looks like an
empty bookshelf and so some people were
irritated by that when they
ios5 they've got this new app that can't
get rid of it because it's a folder not
an app great so you have an app that's
literally an empty bookshelf on your
front of your right right okay so I push
people into wanting to like fill it with
new material the purchases yeah pretty
much um so all these different
publishers are seeing these phenomenal
subscription rates um like in the
hundred like I think Conde Nast over two
hundred percent of future publishing was
in the hundreds as well other people's
um oh we're in like the thousands pretty
crazy numbers so Paul from like one
little app on the front page yeah it
just adds words more visibility to own
ok the next subscription apps cool well
maybe that's a new sort of
revolutionising of the publishing
industry or something on the iPad we
never know yeah anyway next up we're
gonna have my new boss John Phillips
come in to talk about a new google
product hey John Mike how's it going I'm
good so let's talk about Google we went
down there this week right to check out
one of their there the next iteration of
what Google TV right next version of
Google TV I just got an email they're
not calling it version 2 out still just
the next version of Google TV okay Ida
from what I saw it is a big improvement
so for the last week I've been playing
with the current version of Google TV on
Sony set-top box getting very familiar
with it and as I compare sort of what
i'm using now to what google showed us
earlier this week in our little hands-on
demo yeah it's a big improvement
and you know it is a good product such
especially at $99 for the lower end is
cheap yeah it's a good product if you
are sort of addicted to youtube video
and if you want a really good delivery
system for netflix video and the new
version only improves it okay well i
mean so the last one was a flop right
like for all intents and purposes
everyone was just sort of like Chum did
right what why you know how is this a
step up okay so like I forgot the exact
name so the guys we spoke do better I do
too high high very high muckamucks you
know who seem like they know what their
we have VP level huh guy I'm gonna go
crazy not remembering put that in later
um so basically you know I brought up
the question everyone saw the first
google TV as a cord cutting device right
and that you a table you'll be able to
take the set-top box installed it to
your TV and you could immediately cut
your cable or dish access and so Google
is saying no that never was the case you
know as we've learned since the google
TV launch the TV networks did not buy
into that so because you could install
google TV on your system rather your TV
but you couldn't download CBS NBC ABC
internet content directly through google
TV so no it's always been Google style
right they just sort of like push ahead
and then like rather than Apple who
secures the deals in time my google is
just like you know what we're gonna do
this and you can get on better right and
this time it didn't work out and as they
as we were repeatedly told that they're
considering this a marathon not a sprint
right words sort of like this unified TV
platform and so no it's not a court
cutting device but what it does do very
well is brings youtube and netflix and
amazon video on demand and some other
video streaming non-network video
streaming services to a nice software
interface and so where the old software
interface was sort of difficult to use
and hard to find stuff they've made some
key improvements yeah they one thing
they showed us was the
sort of strip along the bottom right so
it's all just really streamlined and
then some of what what I what I really
liked was the sort of integration
between web and TV video right so right
so now there's a new and improved
YouTube app and so before it did have a
youtube app but it sort of was
reminiscent of the web YouTube
experience the new app fires up real
quickly you hit a video and it it
launches instantaneously where I asked
was is this cached on a server somewhere
sort of in anticipation of loading the
most popular videos they said no this is
just the speed of the new app and so you
hit a video boom it's playing it's if
it's HD and they actually have a feature
that allows you to just parse by HD
content it looks like on broadcast video
and using the lean back mode you can
essentially get a sort of like this
curated stream of YouTube videos and
it's a it's a probably the most slick
interpretation of YouTube I've seen yet
that's cool now it's just sort of like
can they make this I don't know if you
want called relaunch or refresh or next
version can they make it work for them
you know especially with these rumors
these rumors were hearing now the
appletv hardware right that are coming I
don't know so yeah Apple TV I i would i
would buy a big screen TV Apple TV if
the came loaded with itunes of my
favorite apps right and as maybe if it
was like siri powered time i ever have
to get off the cat out would be pretty
cool you know what google TV is now
integrating android apps in there and so
that's sort of yeah the other side of
the google TV story where they're
featuring right on a main menu 25 apps
that are optimized for Google TV so I
think they showed us a Wall Street
Journal abso Wall Street Journal has a
lot of video content they don't want to
strike a lot of deals with with cable
providers they could do an end-run
around those people and deliver a nap
straight on Google TV that lets you sort
of parse and walk through all the video
they're already producing so that's like
another cool new feature in that apps
are coming to the Google TV yeah totally
and I think a lot of Android developers
were really excited I I just like the
idea of expanding the platform beyond
you know just phones just tablets and
just sort of moving into the TV space
you know it was gonna happen yeah my
bottom line is if you use YouTube all
time Netflix and you have ninety nine
dollars you want to spend go for it it's
pretty cool cool well that is all the
time we have for today we'll see window
real quickly when does the google TV
refresh sort of roll out ok so it's an
on over-the-air refresh its going to
Sony boxes first then logitech and it
starts on October thirtieth okay cool
alright thanks John we'll see you guys
next week